by a vote of three to zero Tom you are
evicted from the Big Brother house yeah
thank you absolutely written from HOH
uh-huh out the door all in one night
just like life huh
one second you're on top the next second
you're out the door did you see this
coming
oh yeah oh yeah that's why I was
fighting so hard in those competitions
for the last couple of weeks it just was
right there they were gunning for me the
whole time and I just had you know
persevere and fight you know and but I'm
here and I tell you although I'm you
know disappointed that I'm not gonna win
it is nice to see the sky and breathe
air I haven't left I haven't left the
Big Brother house and you know over 20
days or so uh you know it's the first
time as an adult that I I mean it's
first time in my life that I've you know
not been outside for you know
20-something odd days so it's very
strange feeling but it's it's it's good
it's an amazing experience and you know
I'm gonna remember it forever yeah you
became what they call him as Big Brother
we're all too comp beast uh-huh uh-huh
nice really yeah really because you were
winning a competition after competition
yeah I'm a cop beat hump beat Wow add it
to the resume that is cool why do you
think you became a target for the house
what was it well partially what happened
was circumstantial the show started and
I really gravitated towards Anthony
scary Meucci we became really close in
the couple of days that he was there and
Kato Kaelin so there was the three of us
and we were essentially forming the
beginning of an alliance and then boom
all of a sudden the mooch left and
everybody had already formed little
cliques so I was kind of like left high
and dry there off the top and I had to
kind of figure out a way to kind of to
manage my way through it all but but
yeah so like right off the bat there was
sort of couple of groups and they were
all gunning for each other and it was it
was just Kato and I were you know one
group and and and it was it was like an
all-out street fight in there man I
didn't know I was gonna get soaked
crazy yeah we saw you you had to take
some time alone by yourself
I'll talk to yourself yeah what
surprised you the most about this
experience Wow well just honestly the
intensity of it I I knew that people are
competitive and we've got some
incredible athletes in there and some
amazing you know people and I know
everybody wanted to win but just the the
the the real sort of intensity of this
desire to win really got pretty wild and
you know III you know hats off to
everyone in there you know Ricky
Williams and I were kind of you know
going toe-to-toe quite a bit and you
know he's obviously a legend and
football and you sort of sit there
sometimes and go wow you know like it's
Ricky Williams and he's mad at me you
know this is amazing you know but and
then I've also another thing I think is
like you know I've made it made a lot of
friends in there and I knew that I would
but I didn't really expect you know
there's not that often you spend
20-something odd odd days you know day
and night cooking together eating
together sleeping beside each other you
know kato kaelin and i were just sort of
best buds for that whole time and just
spend that much time you really talk
about life you talk about you know you
know everything that you know you know
friends would talk about and you know
all well it's being recorded so some
things you leave out but no so I think
I've definitely made some some friends
that for the future dina Lohan and I we
spent a lot of time hanging out and
talking and and she's hilarious and
amazing ladies so so I think I think
it's gonna be really cool to get to
reconnect with them and talk about this
once everyone's out of the house yeah
the three of you are kind of like a big
brother world odd reverse Three's
Company
you told Julia that you learned about a
lot about human nature in that house
yeah yeah who taught you the most and
what did they teach you well you know
it's it's sort of just the way people
moved amongst each other and towards
each other was kind of like
sort of a fluid sort of you know when
some when a new HOH comes in and you're
no longer the HOH somebody that was you
know for instance when you're not the
HOH people will really let their true
feelings towards you be seen you know if
they don't think you're going to win the
HOH again and Evi all of a sudden are
against you and not smiling as much or
or at all and then suddenly when you win
the competition again and surprise
you're the HOH again all of a sudden
they're very friendly again so I started
to see this hot and cold thing every day
was almost like whiplash you know you go
oh you're you want to be friends again
now you don't wanna be friends and so it
was cool you know I try I tried to sort
of I always I you know I like to analyze
people and and and you know with my
stand-up comedy
I'm always commenting you know on the
world and and people in general and so
I'm always observing everything so I
think maybe it's possible that I saw
some of these little shifts in dynamic
shifts maybe a little more clearly than
others so so but it was great you know
it was I I actually take that I take it
take that as a take away as a positive
thing you know I feel like I I learned a
lot about about life and being a human
being okay yeah now you wait for the 45
oh no I'm okay that's okay
ah you made it a point to say your piece
to everybody before you walked out that
door yeah then when you walked out the
door you held it open so they could see
out for a minute yeah why was that all
important for you to do in your exit
well you know I wanted to exit the game
in a in a positive way you know I know
there's been a lot of intense feelings
and and you know it's been a very fierce
competitive environment and whenever
anybody would leave you know we've been
in there for a long time and just seeing
some other faces out there was always a
very sort of a thrill on us honestly and
you know when people left you know I
think I think a lot of people weren't
necessarily thinking about it so they'd
walk out we'd get a local Imps but I
wanted to kind of just do that as a
gesture of
you know goodwill towards towards
everyone even though we sort of been
through a lot together right I wanted to
say that you know no no hard feelings
it's just again also there was a little
bit of haha
suckers I'm out here and you got to stay
in there um you told Julie that you're
rooting for Lowell oh yeah is she
playing the best game in that house uh I
think she's definitely got a real shot
you know you know I'm also of course I'm
rooting for Dina and I'm rooting for for
candy but you know low-low from the very
beginning she picked me in the first
challenge and you know I know we were at
odds a few times throughout the course
of this but I've always sort of you know
I you know III admire her you know at
her tenacity you know she's she's
chasing her dream and of representing
you know America right and I think she
she deserves the win okay yeah okay
looking at your own game
what's the one thing you would have done
differently well I think probably you
know I really did try to be friends with
everybody and and sometimes you would it
was hard to do that because you know
people would would get into these little
groups but I think maybe I would have
tried a little harder okay you know once
I realized that there was a group that
was maybe you know aligned against me I
I think maybe I could have probably
tried a little harder to to really
connect with people even the people that
were against me but it's hard you know
when you're doing this for the first
time you know your human emotions take
over and you really do kind of I
sometimes I would say in there quite
regularly actually the strangest thing
about being at a Big Brother house is
when you forget that it's weird and that
happens
almost
instantly if it comes your new normal
yeah you know of course I'm just making
dinner with dina Lohan and kato kaelin
nothing strange about this and you
forgetting forget for sometimes a day at
a time that this is this you know you
don't forget the cameras are there you
don't forget you're playing a game but
you kind of forget that it's real it
becomes normal to be in there doing that
so it was very very cool cuz life's
still happening in that house you're
playing a game but there's a lot of life
going on - oh yeah yeah if you had to
sum up this experience with one word
what would your word be for Celebrity
Big Brother
maybe surreal that's a real it's a
pretty good one yeah yeah we'll take
some real I'll say amazing amazing
amazing so real and amazing leave it on
that thank you Tom thank you
[Music]